oh we fired Reggie in the fire hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to factorio we made a goof
we goofed we goofed all over the place
we just sprayed all over Regios yeah we
goofed all over Reggie um yeah poor
Reggie he was old but it wasn't his
fault he was just we weren't feeding our
employees is the problem we were bad
bosses pretty much basically you know
ordinarily you'd have like auto feeders
you know putting coal in these things if
you had your layout all done correctly
but apparently well we could it yeah I
don't have that setup yeah you did not
don't Jeff how would you set that up
well basically you'd have them laid out
in a completely different way than the
way you do now sure sure sure sure sure
sure yeah yeah sure
sound see it yeah ctrl-click doesn't
work it doesn't work
you're good good yeah there it is you
have to have it in your hand well uh
although on the hotbar on the bottom and
then put it in your hand and I would why
would I put it over hopper in my hotbar
like that's like it i keeps : my hotbar
just so I can quickly refill everything
reason yessir I keep it in like the
alternate hot bar the shift bar or
whatever okay I don't have the alternate
hopper oh the one on the right side oh
you can actually research more quick
bars if you feel like yeah yeah we
haven't done that yeah there's no point
in that because we got advanced
materials processing on the way and now
we got copper going to our giant machine
of science so you Bill Nye thing the
giant machine the science machine
processing machine of science are we
wait why are we running out of Steel
what's what what
Oh mommy suck a [ __ ] oh there's not
enough iron plates they're not making it
all the way through anymore what why oh
because potato went down no it's fine
because power went down therefore there
was a style went down power went down
power down it's cool cuz now power is up
and everything's running so now we just
need the copper to get to the place and
I don't know how the hell we're gonna do
that I might have
move one of the science machines but I
think I think you can I think you can
can't you just get copper onto the same
belt and then just let the belt be
grabbable by the copper and starter guy
if we made sure that the steel was only
on one side of the belt and the coppers
on the other side then yes but we can do
it we can do that we can do that there's
a way we can all you have to do is
change the inserters over at the steel
place to the mill and the one problem is
just the inserter that i set up actually
your incisors are set up in a way so
that they all go to the same side and -
ruining it okay so then we just like to
set up an inserter if i get rid of this
stupid useless light as what you
conveyor belt did I do that no I just go
I always stand on the conveyor belts and
slowly move away from what is like ah I
just I just oh yeah now that will all be
on the same side yeah and now in the
copper injected which if we were just
run the copper over on a on a
transporter belt it'll be injected on to
the right side yes yes exactly
so just the overflow line that you have
if you just run it down and I know you
want to put the underground by the road
because this road is never gonna change
can't you just let me have this I'm
agreeing with you right now I'm doing
the agreements as I'm saying okay yes I
understand your methodology for it I get
it I get you I get it and I get you in
you understand why I'm insane well yes
exactly what I'm saying I didn't want to
say that you were insane I just wanted
like right no I I could feel it coming
so you could feel the insanity coming
are you gonna feel my credit I can feel
you coming actually I don't have any
underground um so [ __ ] it you're out of
underground no I have underground boss
boss no don't do it like that that's
fine that's perfect oh that is perfect
you're right that is perfect why is that
not good that lapel is fine to me it's
absolutely fine that's exactly what we
wanted actually yeah it is it's you're
right I'm wrong III take blame for that
that is that is my fault
see look it's not
it's like you wanted it goes around the
road right I appreciate that
I appreciate that oh no that's not good
this can't happen because oh wait no it
can't happen it's good it's fine this is
fine you're right it's fine
don't don't question it this is fine
you're right it's fine I wish there was
more copper I'm going to realize we can
up the copper production or replace
Ernesto with a slower grabby grabber
yeah um actually just make the to
regular furnaces into steel furnaces and
will be much better oh I can do that do
that but on side road every day gosh doc
don't look at me rigid oh look at my
shame I can't I do dumb well this is a
game for the dumb so it's totally ouch
fine no no no no not like that I mean
I'm just saying how incredibly smart
you aren't uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh so yeah
I could feel it coming
Hey so you could feel me coming again
you could feel mark I could feel you
coming from a mile away I do I do I just
want to say it makes me happy inside my
heart that this is like this hey I'm
here for you and just because you have
the nose of really work that you really
looking out for me but yet you have the
nose of a shark and you can smell me
coming from aa it means a lot this is
like too clogged with conveyor we need
like a smart grabber taking a little a
little a little a little conveyor a
little overflow huh I think I can put it
right here and it'll be super chill and
then we'll have all the conveyor we want
we'll we'll never have to worry about
getting conveyor again because we'll
have extras yeah that one conveyor
machine is really pumping out everything
that we are [ __ ] it what sound like
an infinitive what the hell man yes and
what's like the gear makers like just
one gear maker is pretty much enough I
didn't need to make two I just
I'm asinine and wanted it to be
symmetrical so sure okay but this is
good because the interior loop is doing
fine it's got enough of everything it
just needs more
Electrical production but there's plenty
of that I'm going to take out the filter
for the copper cable and everything's
gonna be good your shits aren't there
very many inserters okay the inserters
are starting to come back in on the
outside okay yeah because it was just
too flooded it's what I like them yeah
so now this is a lot of this is a lot of
stuff going on look at all this I know
right it's exciting I helped you helped
you did you did most of the work Bob you
you did all this
it was just I did a lot of the thinking
work it every time I went oh what the
[ __ ] am i doing where the [ __ ] you would
go this you stepped in and rescued the
day because you're hired thank you you
saved everything okay sir is there a
crucial research I'd like to get solar
power but we don't really super need
that yeah we we got enough power power
is never there probably we need to go in
um the only direction that I'd think
that we need is we we could get drone
bots we need um that would be cool
yeah drone BOTS that work for us so what
we need to do is we need to okay we need
flight with six robots Oh advanced
electronics - we get robotics yeah
exactly
so that allows us electronics - we need
yeah so all this system with the
conveyors and [ __ ] this will be
irrelevant if we get like robots that
can just fly the [ __ ] where we needed to
go it's so cool where's where's flight
flight is probably not even oh no eight
flight is like fourth row third from the
right
if you see Jenna ah-ha so we just need
engines electric engine yeah we didn't
get yet yeah we'll need four electric
engines we need engine okay so we need
to do advanced robotics electrolyte rise
two engines electric engines flight very
correct yes and then the logistics
robots will be able to transport
everything everywhere we need it was
really quiet always had wondered how ups
had such good logistics
I never took into account the electric
engines and flight that they
investigated for themselves
yeah but I really didn't laugh so second
I like having through I was like man you
should just bail no [ __ ] me oh it was
good Babu good try so hard and uh didn't
really get that far yeah just didn't
even matter um okay so now everything is
doing super cool I'm just gonna have to
our pollution is now it's flashing
spreading onto the red the red dot down
there to the southeast ah that doesn't
sound good
about to start covering them it looks
like okay so an attack is eminent or
something attack isn't wait oh no oh no
oh no the interior loop it's putting
copper on the on the Oh horses why is
that happening because Oh God
because uh I philip defranco in here it
needs to be a smart ones jumping you
[ __ ]
I'm clearing the loop I got I got a
smart one I'll smart him oh god it's so
hard to clear the loop when you got lag
okay she's crazy
we're good we're fine everything's fine
alright alright it's fixed everything's
fixed it's okay everything's 100% fix
the only thing we have is like we almost
have too much uh oh because much copper
this copper box is full so um oh why is
this a wooden chest in the age of
stealing of a wooden chest everything I
don't know
I forget that some of this old stuff is
just here from like the the ancient days
of the Soviet Union and everything's
been for a pop eh Bob Stephanie 20 Bob
stone-age mmm Bob's of the Stone Age my
favorite bands Johnny Bob's anything
I'm the Bob siders guess my age win a
prize
Bob stone age eyes a good that was a
good jobs better than make sense that
was funnier than the fly joke is joke I
mean I you know this whole times like
since we started playing this game and
started talking about the logistics
stuff in my mind
other's ups choking ah logistics like
it's right there
so for so UPS is logistics so for many
hours of recording that's the best I
could come up with six episodes and then
like two three hours of recording just
like you you had it crap you're like yes
yes yes UPS invented flight I don't know
God just leave me alone
I can't leave you alone we're literally
in this together we have nowhere to go
except up until 8:00 like what UPS made
like like that being that UPS yet
invention jokes yeah we're doing it okay
anyway so now we need to UM oh come on
is to two thingies
next we need okay so we're receipt reira
Street tree ring okay do you want to go
stupid
it's a baited ship like I can't say that
word shut up yes that what happened I
didn't just bury che stirring advanced
electronics where should we go do you
want do you want to go a kill a alien
nest thing because your resources or
something from that we get these special
items called alien artifacts and deeper
in the research tree you will see that
there's something in there for utilizing
I did go but anyway the the alien
artifacts are actually used in crafting
down the road and also it's just in that
I just see there's like alien tech
somewhere in there that's yeah so
shotgun is way better than the machine
gun so I would recommend shot myself a
shotgun yeah and not have enough iron of
course not
and the the extra special benefit of it
is you can bring a gun turret with you
plant it outside of the camp and that
way whenever you get panicked you just
run back to your gun turret it'll kill
everything and then everything will be
cool ah I needed sort of you to here you
can have all of them goddamn thank you I
mean would I died but I wouldn't story I
got no I got woody there's a box in the
middle you know they're really creepy
right here that I could no no it's a box
it's got hundreds of wood I there's a
bar gets right here I just put on use my
wood it's over here in my box mark
there's like an infinite these are the
boxes you made these aren't my boxes oh
that's right I made you ladies do okay
then no need to panic it's cool
everything's cool everything's cool
don't worry about it cool I'm just gonna
get the rest of this science and then
we're gonna put this in here okay
everything is 100% fine
we got lots of science I'll get so much
all the time the only thing we don't
have actually we're running low on red
science of all things yeah my red
science it's really shitty I don't know
why we didn't fix that well it's awful
okay you miss a good system for that why
did you allow my system to be the one
that we continued to use the system for
this by I could how awful it is it could
very quickly make a red science loop and
it'd be super easy and I could do it in
no time do you want me to do that for
you yeah let's just do you want me to
just disassemble all this red sign no no
no no it's cool is this I don't even
think this is making anything conveyor
but it's not making anything no it's
cool they are belting [ __ ] around do do
you can we use our iron and copper
supply line split that off can we use a
splitter to split that into two lines
and uh and then use that to supply both
of our science I think most definitely
we can
and cuz that'd be an intelligent use of
the tools that we have available right
right like what if like as if in like
such as the Iran like such as yes all of
that is it just gonna split it perfectly
one into copper and one into no I think
it splits it into two identical rows of
whatever it is I'd be more helpful I
think that's what it does I'm crafting a
whole ass load of ammo I will make it
then honor I'm making I'm making as
normal minutes are showing I'm going I'm
going okay I got it
okay okay okay
I have no idea then we did work Oh mark
I had that idea and then I did it Wow
I'm so proud of you Bob that works great
you are good at this game
good job alright so built your [ __ ] and
we got a supply line you knew the hard
part I I made the splitting of the
supply lines thanks thanks Bob
okay so this is super easy it's super
easy to I just need three more Miceli
and assembling them Bob you're standing
right where I want to place it again
here haha here damn there we go hey I
was gonna go for a swim you do whatever
you're gonna do or whatever it's it's
super easy to do because there's really
nothing to it you just get these three
working on science lots of power lines
later not yet don't put them in yet we
don't need them yet it's so Tim and Bob
I mean you're I like they go away so
from I do this a lot don't worry about
it okay yeah it's just that's what you
do when you're on your own you're just
spastically putting poles down and then
taking them up don't stop you know fun
and games
okay I do man so the cool thing about
this is the only thing that needs to be
on the belt on the inside is copper
because copper and gears so gears need
to be on one side of the line copper
needs to be on the other side and then
it's literally unlimited on what you can
do so such as the Iran this will go like
this hey I'll bring I'll bring the
Copperfield over here don't don't you
worry about it okay you just bring that
over bring it over right here okay cool
thank you
you are a delight do I need to feed it
into this line right here not yes not
yes
Khan okay okay so here's where it's
gonna be complicated one of the we're
gonna have long handles [ __ ] there's a
lake in the way god titty [ __ ] crappy
Christmas Bulls they just change which
side the gear production is on No
[ __ ] this [ __ ] goddamn piece of [ __ ]
Lake [ __ ] can we get rid of the lake
with our guns oh my god light are you
crazy
can we get rid of this [ __ ] helping
me carry this locker goddamn I just got
to move everything over one [ __ ] son of
a [ __ ] your life is so hard yeah
alright we're actually out of time for
this episode but well this will be done
next time we come back understand
understood okay everyone's happy about
it
everyone is cool with it alright so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always we'll see you in the next
video
I can come from behind this 2d world
actually has a 3d aspect you stop
grunting in my ear